let's use what we've learned about
finding the minimums and maximums of
functions to solve some optimization
problems and you might be wondering sal
what is an optim optimization problem
and my reply to you as well
the problems we're about to do are
optimization problems and i think you'll
you'll understand why they're called
optimization problems anyway so the
first problem is
find two numbers whose product is
negative 16 so the product
is equal to -16
and it says and the sum of whose squares
is a minimum
so sum of squares
sum of squares
is minimum
so if you haven't figured out yet these
optimization problems all figure they'll
all
impose some type of constraints and then
say
you know so for what numbers do we get a
maximum value or a minimum value um well
really usually just max more minimum so
let's do this problem and then we'll do
a couple more so two numbers whose
products whose product is negative 16
and the sum of their squares is a
minimum so let's just
let's say call those two numbers x and y
so the product is minus 16 so we know
that x times y
is equal to minus 16.
and then what's the sum of their squares
so let's just say the sum of squares
sorry i'll just call that
s
the sum of their squares is going to be
equal to x squared
plus y squared
and so this is the function that we want
to optimize and in this case we want to
find the minimum value so what are how
do we do this problem well the first
thing we want to do this we want to
minimize this function but right now
it's a function of two variables and we
haven't done multi-variable calculus yet
so it would be easier if we just found
if we could express this as a function
of one variable and then we could
optimize it with respect to that
variable and we could substitute
backwards et cetera et cetera so how can
we write the sum of the squares as a
function of one variable well that's
where this equation comes in handy we
could substitute either for x or y let's
just
substitute y so we could rewrite this
equation dividing both sides by x as y
is equal to
minus 16
over x
right
so if we take this i just divide both
sides of this by x if we take this and
substitute it here we get the sum of the
squares of the two numbers
is going to be equal to
x squared plus y squared well why is
this so it's what's this thing squared
minus 16 squared is 256
and over x squared
so that's the sum of the squares of the
two numbers
and so how do we learn to find minimums
or maximums or in general optimize a
function
well in general a function hits a
minimum or maximum point especially a
local minimum or maximum point when its
derivative is zero
so let's take the derivative of this and
set it equal to zero and hopefully we
find a minimum point and then we'll
later show that it really is a minimum
point
so let's take the derivative of this
with respect to x i'll just write s
prime we could have written d s dx but
i'll
save on notation
save on my electronic ink
so s prime is equal to so this is the
slope of this function anytime at any x
2 x
plus this is the same thing as 256 times
x to the negative 2
right
so what will be the derivative the
derivative is going to be
we multiply by times exponent which is
minus 2 and then we decrement the
exponent by once we get x to the minus
3.
so the derivative is equal to
2 x
plus no not plus
2x minus
5 12
times x to the minus 3. and we want to
find a local minima or maximum or maybe
a global one so we want to figure out
where the slope is equal to zero so we
this is the slope so let's set this
equal to zero
so we get
two
x minus
5 12
x to the minus 3 is equal to 0.
let's see we can
manipulate that around a little bit we
get 2x
let me do a different color i'm tired of
the yellow
we could then whoops
so you get
just going up here
we get just let's add 512 to both sides
so we get 2
x
is equal to
x to the minus 3 right i just added 5 12
to both sides and let's multiply both
sides of this equation times x to the
third
just to get rid of this
so if we multiply both sides of the
equation by x to the third we get
x to the fourth
is equal to 5 12
right x to the third times x to the
minus three that just equals one
divide both sides of this by two you get
x to the fourth
is equal to 256
and if it's not immediately clear what
this is we you know x is going to be the
fourth root of 256 if you don't know
that immediately you can think well
what's the square root of 256 well it's
16 and then what's the square root of
that well the square root of 16 is is
plus or minus
so the square root of this is plus or
minus 16 but then the square root of at
least the plus 16 is plus or minus four
so this x is equal to
x is equal to plus or minus four and if
you don't believe me take either minus
four or positive four and take it to the
fourth power and you will get 256. so if
x is plus or minus 4 what is y
well we just know that y is minus 16
divided by x so let's say
we so we could get x is 4 if x is 4 then
what is y
it's minus 16 divided by 4 then y is
equal to -4
and of course if x was minus 4
then y is minus 16 divided by minus 4 y
would be equal to 4. so it actually
doesn't matter which one we take the two
numbers are 4 negative 4. it doesn't
matter what we call them x or y
the two numbers are 4 and minus 4. and
we are actually done the problem these
are the two numbers where the sum of the
squares well actually no we are not done
we know that we've reached some type of
minimum or maximum point here and
since they asked for a minimum and this
was the only point that we found where
the slope was 0
we probably solved the problem but let's
prove to ourselves that we're really at
a minimum point on this function on this
function
when x is equal to 4. and how do we do
that well we could take the second
derivative of this function see what the
second derivative is at x equals 4 and
then see if we're concave upwards or
concave downwards
so let's see this is the first
derivative this was the first derivative
that's the first derivative
what is the second derivative
so s prime prime
s prime prime is equal to what's this 2
and then we'll see minus
3 times minus 5 12 so that's plus
and what is that 15 36
right plus 15 36
36 times x
to the minus 4.
right
so
what is s prime prime i actually you
know i should be writing s as a function
of x i shouldn't i should be i shouldn't
be lazy with my notation
these are all as a function of x but you
get the point so what is s
prime prime
when x is equal to 4
what's equal to 2
plus
36 and then what's 4 to the minus 4
power well we it's 1 over 256 times 1
over 256. and we don't even have to
calculate this all we care about is this
value positive or negative and it is
clearly positive we have a positive
number plus a positive number divided by
a positive number so we have a positive
number here
so what do we know we know at the point
x is equal to 4 at the point x is equal
to 4
this function here our our sum of
squares function
is concave upwards and we know that
because the second derivative at x is
equal to 4 is positive and what does
concave upwards look like concave
upwards looks like this
and so x equals 4 is there and so we are
at a minimum point
and so we know that the sum of squares
are minimum and if you really want to
make sure that you're not missing
something or we haven't done this wrong
think of other just you know play around
think of other numbers whose product is
-16 and figure out their sum of squares
and and i can pretty much guarantee you
that it will be larger than the sum of
the squares of four
of minus four and four and so what
actually what are they what is the what
is s of four what is the sum of squares
of 4 and minus 4. it's 4 squared is 16
plus 16 is 32 right
that's the sum so let's try some other
numbers what is the sum of
of
1 squared
plus i don't know minus 16 squared right
those two have the product minus 16 1
and minus 16.
that is equal to what 257 much higher
number try you could try negative 8 and
2 or negative 2 and 8. and everything
you'll find will have a higher sum of
squares than four and minus four anyway
that i was i was actually planning on
doing three problems in this video but
i'm reaching the 10 minute limit so i
will finish this video now and i will do
two more of these optimization problems
see you soon